على تخوم الحدود بين الكراهيه
والمعدات كشف فيلم ولايات الخوف الذي
انتجته الجزيره وبثته الاحد كشف تنامي
ظاهره الاسلاموفوبيا او الخوف من الاسلام
ويظهر الفيلم الذي شكل جوهره حلقه من
البرنامج التحقيقي شاهد عيان ان نشر
المشاعر المتوج سه من الاسلام والمسلمين
لم يات اعتباطا فمن يخلق تلك المشاعر وما
غاياته وهل تلاقيهم مع بعض من قرارات
الاداره الامريكيه الجديده محض صدفه نتابع
تقرير معد البرنامج الزميل عبد الله
الشب ميليشيات مسلحه في احدى غابات جورجيا
جنوب شرق الولايات المتحده تضم الكبار
والصغار تتدرب خوفا كما تقول من عدو قد
ياتي في اي وقت واستعدادا له هذه مجموعه
ضمن عشرات تنشط في الولايات المتحده ترى
ان الخطر داهم ويجب اخذه ماخذ
الجد لنقل ان هناك علما لتنظيم الدوله
يحلق فوق مبنى المحافظه في اتلانتا سنذهب
الى هناك وننهي الموقف سريعا وننقذ
الابرياء لكن لا وجود للعلم الا في
مخيلتهم وبدلا من ذلك تذهب الميليشيا الى
مبنى المحافظه بسلاحها لتمنع بناء
مسجد هي جزء من شبكه منظمه تدير الخطاب
المعادي للاسلام في الولايات المتحده
اطرافها ممول يدعمون مراكز ابحاث تنتج
الخطاب ثم شره ليصل الى مختلف فئات
المجتمع شخصيات تكرس جل جهدها لصناعه خطاب
اعلامي معادل للاسلام ولا تنكر صلتها
بصناع
القرار اعتقد انه سيكون لنا دور اكبر في
اداره ترامب من دورنا في فتره اوباما نحن
متصلون بهذه الاداره بشكل اقوى المسلم
المعتدل هو شخص يريد ان يعيش في عالم عصري
هو مسلم يعيش بالطريقه الاسلاميه
لا يريد ان يعود الى الوراء الى القرن
السابع الهجري ويكرر ما كان يفعله النبي
محمد مئات الملايين من الدولارات دفعت على
مدى سنوات لبلوغ هذا التاثير يتمثل خطر
هذه الشبكه كما يحكي الفيلم في قرب
اعمدتها من اداره الرئيس الجديد دونالد
ترامب اسماء نافذه داخل هذه الاداره مثل
ستيفان بانون كبير المستشارين وكبير
المخططين الاستراتيجيين الذي سبق ان نعت
الاسلام بالدين الاكثر تطرفا في العالم
الاسلاموفوبيا في امريكا ليست ولده اليوم
لكنها باتت تاخذ شكلا علميا واكاديميا
وتجد لها في ظل الاداره الجديده طريقا الى
وسائل الاعلام والساسه ونتيجه قرارات
سياسيه وتشريعات كان مواطنوا سبع دول
اسلاميه اول ضحاياها في الايام الاولى من
عهد
ترامب ينضم الينا من عمان داني اليبس رئيس
منتدى الشرق الاوسط ومن واشنطن روبرت
الكنزي المستشار في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه لشؤون العالم الاسلامي لكننا
نبدا مع الزميل عبد الله الشامي معد فيلم
ولايات
الخوف عبد الله يعني ما الذي رصدته ما
الذي شاهدته ويمكنك يعني باجازه ان تخبرنا
عنه من خلال لقائك لهذه الميليشيات
المسلحه ابرز ما لفت نظرك
نعم شكرا عثمان في البدايه هذه الميليشيات
هي
ليست بضع او مجموعه قليله وانما هي حسب
اخر التقارير الصادره تفيد بانها وصلت الى
عدد 200 و76 مجموعه في عام
2015 هذه المجموعات ازدادت بشكل لافد بعد
انتخاب الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما و
مواقفها تختلف من واحده لاخرى هنالك من
يرى في الحكومه الامريكيه شخصيا عدوا له
لكن
ا هذه المجموعه التي قابلناها بالتحديد
مجموعه جزء من مجموعات اكبر تطلق على
نفسها نسبه ال 3% وهي جزء من المجتمع
الامريكي يرى ان الامريكيين الاصليين كما
يصفونهم فقط هم هؤلاء 3% الذين حاربوا ما
يسمونه الاحتلال البريطاني لامريكا في
القرنين الثام عشر والتاس عشر هم يرون ان
امريكا مكان خالص فقط للبيض وللمس حين
وليست لسواهم وبالتالي كما راينا في
الفيلم
كانوا اصحاب مواقف قويه ضد مثلا بناء مسجد
في احدى المقاطعات وطاع ان يمنعوا ذلك كما
جاء في في تقريرك في قرب نهر هيدسون من
خلال معلوماتك هل هذه مجموعات مسلحه
قانونيه ام محظوره ما هو وضعها
القانوني يعني حسب ما لدي من معلومات هذه
المجموعات في بمساله حمل السلاح والتدرب
عليه ليس هنالك ما يمنع داخل القانون
الامريكي من ذلك وفقا للماده الثانيه او
ما يطلق عليه السكند اممت في الدستور
الامريكي لكن اللفت للنظر هنا انه على
صعيد اخر هنالك مجموعه في شمال نيويورك من
المسلمين في منطقه تسمى اسلام بيرج تتطرق
اليها الفيلم ا هنالك الكثير من الاتهامات
والاشياء التي يتم التحدث عنها من كونهم
مسلحين وخلافه وهو ما لم
يعني نستطيع اصلا التبين منه وتبين عدم
صحته في الفيلم لكن على الرغم من ذلك
الخطاب الاعلامي تجاه هذه المجموعه وغيرها
من المجتمعات المسلمه في الولايات المتحده
اشد بكثير من مثلا هذه المجموعه هذه
المجموعه على المقابل عندما قامت بالتظاهر
بسلاحها في ولايه
جورجيا لم يتم التعامل معها وانما فقط
يعني الاكتفاء ب يعني
ا منع بناء المسجد بل بالعكس تاخير بناء
المسجد لكن لم يتم التعامل معها فيما اذا
كانت اذا ما تصورنا مجموعه مثلا مسلمه
مسلحه شكرا جزيلا لك زميل عبد الله الشامي
معد فيلم ولايات الخوف اعود الى ضيفي سيد
روبرت مكنزي ما
تعليقك على نشاط مثل هذه المجموعات
المسلحه وما حجمها ومدى
تاثيرها
في الحقيقه انا متحفظ عن التحدث عن هذه
المجموعات المسلحه لانني غير مدرك حول حجم
هذه المجموعات ولم اشاهد الوثائق لكنني ما
اعرفه انها موجه ربما متزايده من التعصب
والخوف من الاسلام الامر لا يلمس المسلمين
لكن يلمس المجتمعات والاقليات في الحقيقه
هنالك
جريمه اكثر من 00 جريمه كراهيه وهذا الامر
لا يستهدف
المسلمين المسلمين فقط بل الاقليات وهذا
الامر والاعداد متزايده منذ الانتخابات
الامر يؤثر على اليهود على الشواذ على
المسلمين وبدون اي شك فان هذا الامر اتى
نتيجه لنتائج الانتخابات لذلك يجب علينا
ان نق ونفكر في وجهتنا المستقبليه سيد
دانيل بايبس مراكز البحث التي تتبنى خطابا
دعنا نقل ليس ودودا تجاه المسلمين الى اي
مدى هي قريبه من دائره صنع القرار في
اداره الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب بشكل واضح عن الاسلام المتطرف
بطريقه ان سابق جور دب بوش
وك لم يقولوه ولم يفعلوه واعتقد ان هذا
تطور ايجابي ذلك انه لكي نتعامل مع مشكله
اسلامو علينا ان نتحدث عن اسلامو ولا
اعتقد ان هذا هو هذا لا يثر وليس ضد
المسلمين واود ان اوضح شيئين حقيقتين
اولها انها كثير من الهجمات حصلت ضد
اليهود اكثر م ما حصلت على المسلمين
وثانيا ان عدد السكان المسلمين في
الولايات المتحده في زياده مستمره
وبالتالي هذه ليست مشكله ولكن
هناك عدد كبير من الاسلامويين في الولايات
المتحده بعضهم يستخدمون العنف الاخرون لا
يسمحون لا يستخدمون العنف يعني سؤالي كان
عن قرب هذه المراكز من الاداره
الامريكيه مركزكم على سبيل المثال مركز
بحث انا ما اود فهمه اذا كان هناك امر
ممنهج الى اي مدى مراكز البحث هذه على
علاقه باداره دونالد ترامب مراكز بحث
تتبنى خطاب مثل
خطابكم في الحكم منذ حوالي 40 يوما ولا
اعتقد انه يمكن ان نكد ذلك هذه الحقائق
فنحن منذ عا
97 تعرض لهجوم على يد
الاسلاميين وان كثير من الامريكان مسلمين
غير مسلمين يشعرون بقلق من الهجمات
التاليه وهذا واقع وحقيقه وليس مساله
علاقه بالاداره الامريكيه سيد مكنزي هل
يعني البعض يشبه الامر بان هناك صناعه
لسلامو فوبيا ويعتبر ان اداره الرئيس
الامريكي دونالد ترامب
موغله في هذا الامر هذه الاداره والنافذ
فيها مثل ستيفن بانن وهو كبير المخططين
الاستراتيجيين او المستشارين
الاستراتيجيين لدونالد ترامب الى اي قدر
هم قادرون على تنفيذ ما يريدونه في ظل
مجتمع امريكي فيه نسبه كبيره ايضا من
التسامح يجب ان
نقول
في الحقيقه لم اسمع
بسبب الصعوبات التقنيه ما قاله السيد بايب
لكنني في الحقيقه هو فعلا في اليوم
الاربعين لرئاسه السيد ترامب في الحقيقه
الامر اعتقد ان جرائم الكراهيه في ازدياد
وعندما نتحدث عن المجتمعات الاقليات سواء
ما كانوا مسلمين ام يهود لديهم الحق بان
يقلقوا هنالك معابد تم مهاجمتها هنالك
مقابر تم تدنيسها هذه اشياء حقيقيه تحدث
وهنالك
رابط واضح بين هذا ما يحدث الان وبين لغه
الخطاب التي تاتي من الاداره اذا ما اعتقد
ان هنالك حد فاصل فانه بامكاننا ان نرى
مجتمعات عاده لا تتعاون مع بعضها البعض
اصبحت فجاه متحركه وموحده عبر البلاد لانه
هنالك ش بالقلق شعور عميق بالقلق لذلك
اعتقد ان ربما هذا الشي يجب انلا نتجاهله
اعتقد ان هنالك هذا يمثل شيئا ايجابي انه
هنالك محاوله لصد هذه الموجه نعم نستطيع
التحدث عن الاسلاموفوبيا لكننا يجب ان نرى
الامر خلال
سياق اكبر واعلى مثلا كراهيه الاجانب
وكراهيه الاخر مثلا اذا ما نظرنا الى اي
شخص يقوم بتعقب جرائم الكراهيه نحن لا
تتحدث فقط عن الجرائم ضد المسلمين والعرب
لكن هنالك مجموعات اخرى وهنالك
الكثير تم مهاجمتهم لان شكلهم يوحي بانهم
عرب او مسلمين كان هنالك قبل ايام حادثه
قتل لشخص هندي واعتقدوا ان هذا الامر وهذه
الامور يجب ان تقلقنا نحن لا نرى من
قيادتنا وما قيادتنا في البيت الابيض لا
نرى اي قياده على
الاطلاق ونريد من قادتنا في واشنطن ان
يقفوا وصدوا لهذا الامر دع نشرك السيد
بايبس في في النقاش سيد السيد بايبس السيد
ماكنزي يشعر بالقلق وكثير من الامريكيين
يشعرون بالقلق ان كنت قد شاهدت حفل
الاوسكار البارحه على سبيل المثال الكل
كان يتحدث عن
مخاوفهم من من هذا الخطاب الى اي مدى
برايك يشكل خطرا على السلم الاهلي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لان هناك من
يتاثر بهذا الخطاب شخص احرق مسجدا او او
قتل اشخاص في مسجد في كندا قال انه تاثر
بخطاب يميني من هذا
النوع اعتقد ان الشيء الهام هو ليس
التركيز على الخطابات الصادره من بيت
الابيض بل التركيز على المشكله
الاسلامويين في الولايات المتحده قالوا
نعم هناك مشكله وهناك اعمال متكرره
لعنف وهناك اعمال اعتداءات ثقافيه يجب ان
توقف والاسلاميون لابد ان يوقفوا والان
ذاك انا متاكد المخاوف لن تستمر لان هذا
التحدي
الاسلامي عنيف غير عنيف الذي عانينا منه
ما شاهدناه في البيت الابيض في شخص الرئيس
الجديد هو الرد على ذلك الحل لا يكمن في
ان نغير الرئيس بل بل ان على المؤسسه
الاسلاميه ان تحي تحكي بشكل واضح ضد هذا
التوجه
الاسلامويين سيد روبرت ماكنزي لا ادري اذا
سمعت ما قاله السيد بايبس او كنت ما زلت
تعاني من مشاكل
تقنيه نعم لقد سمعته نريد ما نريده ان
نواجه لغه الخطاب لغه الكراهيه لكن هو
حقيقه ما يحدث حقيقه ان اليات المتحده
لديها 3.3 مليون مسلم يعيشون حياه طبيعيه
هذا هذه حقيقه وحقيقه اخرى ان 10% من
اطبائنا هم من الم المسلمين وان هنالك
اموال اكثر من 100 ال دولار تم جمعها من
اجل
تصليح الضرر الذي احدث بالمقبره اليهوديه
وهذه كلها حقائق واضا مسلمون نعم جمات في
اورندا هنالك الكثير من الدعم الذي قدم
للضحايا والناجين اذا ما كان هنالك خطاب
كراهيه ياتي من اي مجتمع يجب ان نتعامل
معه لكنني اعتقد ايضا اننا نجب ان نبقي
الامور في
سياقها حقيقه اخرى انه منذ احداث الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر فيما يتعلق بحوادث والوفي
داخل الولايات المتحده التي تمكن تسمى
الارهابيه
هنالك عدد اقل من الاقل من الهجمات
التي تم القيام بها من قبل جهاديين من قبل
اشخاص اخرين
هنالك موت واحد هو كثير لكنني يجب ان ابقي
الامور في منظورها الحقيقي لذلك اعتقد ان
هذا هو جوابي لما ذكره السيد شكرا لكما
روبرت الكنزي المستشار في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه لشؤون العالم اسلامي وكان معنا
من عمان دانييل بايبس رئيس منتدى الشرق
الاوسط